There will be a few theorems in this
section
and let's prove the first one, the
Breakpoint Theorem.
First, let's define the notions of
adjacencies and breakpoints looking at
this permutation.
+3 and +4 are arranged in the
right order.
In the same order they are arranged in the
identity permutation.
Let's call it, an adjustment.
+4 and +5 is the same story.
+5 and -12 is definitely out of
order.
And certainly, there should be a
breakpoint that cuts between them.
So, there should be a reversal with one of
its endpoints between +5 and -12
because otherwise, we will never be
able to transform this permutation into
that identity permutation.
-12, -8, also breakpoint.
This is an interesting case:
-8 and -7.
It's not +7 and +8 as we want to
see in the identity permutation, but maybe
there will be a reversal
that contains both -8 and -7 and
then after reversing,
they will turn into a perfect permutation
and will correspond to the case
+7 and +8 and that's why we say
-8 and -7 are in order,
despite being inverted.
-7, -6... the same story.
-6 +1 is definitely a breakpoint,
adjacency breakpoint.
This is also a breakpoint, think about why
it is a breakpoint.
Again, breakpoint, breakpoint and finally,
adjacency.
We're done not quite yet, because there
are two more implicit elements of this
permutation, 0 and n+1 that
describe the start and end of this
permutation.
And 0, +3 is the break point because
0 should not be next to +8,
it should be next to +1.
And +14 and +15 is adjacency.
So after we define adjacencies and
breakpoints, clearly the number of adjacencies
plus the number
of breakpoints in the permutation equals
to the length of the permutation plus 1.
And before we go further, I want to ask
you a question.
Well, what is the number of breakpoints in
the identity permutation,
+1, +2, ..., +n?
Of course, this permutation has no
breakpoints, zero, which means
that sorting by reversal is essentially
breakpoint elimination.
Let's see how it works.
So let's start from the initial
permutation that has six breakpoints.
We move next, there are only four
breakpoints left.
We move left, again, four breakpoints
left.
We move further, two breakpoints, and
finally, in the identity
permutation, zero breakpoints,which means
that every sorting by
reversal should reduce the number of
breakpoints from six to
zero in this case.
We don't know what sequence of reversal is
minimal, but we know that any or each of
them will
result in the reduction of the number of
breakpoints to zero.
Next question: how many breakpoints can be
eliminated by a single reversal?
Well, the answer to this question is
simple; reversal has two ends and nothing
happens with these breakpoints on the left
and on the right of those end points.
Also, every breakpoint that
existed within this interval will remain
the breakpoint.
And therefore, the only breakpoints that
can be affected by
reversals are the two breakpoints on the
end of the reversals.
And since at every step, the number of
breakpoints can be reduced by at most,
two, we have the breakpoint theorem.
Reversal distance should be larger or
equal than the number of breakpoints
over/divided by two.
And it also immediately suggests a new
Greedy algorithm
and probably a better Greedy algorithm for
sorting by reversal.
Indeed, the only thing we need to do to
sort a permutation
optimally is to reduce the number of
breakpoints by two at every step.
Let's look at our segments
of sorting by reversals and we see that at
this step, we did something silly.
We were supposed to be reducing the number
of breakpoints by two
at every step, but the number of
breakpoints
actually has not even reduced at this
reversal.
Maybe we should have chosen another
reversal that would reduce
the number of breakpoints by two, but you
can check that
there is no such reversal.
And in fact, there are permutations for
which there are no reversal reducing
number of
breakpoints even by one, which means
whatever you
do, the number of breakpoints remains the
same.
And that's why it turns out that the
algorithm for sorting by reversals is
actually quite complex.
Even if I had an hour or two
of time one on one with you, I wouldn't be
able to explain all
intricacies of the polynomial algorithm
for sorting by reversals.
And that's why I will switch from the
problem of sorting by reversal
to a different, seemingly even more
difficult problem of
finding rearrangements
and optimal sorting by
of multi-chromosomal genomes.